for like eventually I feel like a good
woman goes through so much before she
actually gets the goods black go through
so many men while like you're giving
your all you're giving yourself now a
good woman good women good women get
picked quick I mean like they might take
one come on they might take one or two
else yeah like they might I'm not
talking about a minute five six hours
but not usually like there's a girl I
knew in college and she was she was
honestly cute like she was she wasn't
like stunning but like she was she's
cute right but men were just like when
you got the right morals it wasn't even
she knows she was just really feminine
yeah um and she was a Christian and like
men were lined up to date her because of
the way she made them feel she never had
an issue with men taking advantage of
her she never had an issue with men you
know um being in situationships like she
got the relationship easy because she
was kind she was loving and she was
selfless yeah but like the women that
always complain about being taken
advantage of usually they're not doing
something